I think - what's interesting is the
mental health that also needs to be
preserved and it was Ross Valory I
believe that gave an incredibly moving
interview on so many people sign up for
fame being a rock star so glamorous but
they don't actually realise what it
entails and once they get it they're
either too exhausted or they can't
handle the responsibility yeah what was
happening this day because I mean that
was a moving interview that he gave that
I mean it really made you think yeah you
think about the Kurt Cobain's and the 27
club of Janis Joplin and all those
people what was going on that day you
know I always say Ross is like he was my
go-to person
he's like the institutional memory of
journey he's he was he's an original
member he's seen all the ups and the
downs he's seen what can do to family to
band members her I mean the conventional
wisdom is a band is always breaking up
right and I can see that I can see that
happening because it's all these really
strong personalities in one room and
they in day out like on tour which is
grueling but also I was catching journey
at a time when they had all settled it's
like the mature journey you know that
would sure rock star and they were there
and they were there to help
Arnel get through this summer because
the success of right now was their
success they understood that so they
were all on board for that so it was
that day that was Ross going back and
thinking wow this could have gone so
awry in other times right but because
they were where they were they could
look back and understand what Fame does
that they were able to all get together
and help this guy and I think that's why
I missed this documentary is very
different from all the other rock talks
you've seen rock talks about the
fighting right the this you know
storming out and slamming doors and and
you know all the walkouts
this is not that this is a story of how
this guy Arnel Pineda joins one of the
most famous iconic rock bands in
American pop history and how he's able
to integrate
and really succeed succeed and how do
you do that and still keep some kind of
sanity
you